how's it going everyone we've had a few
days with hunt showdown alpha which is a
PvP game with perma death set in a PvE
swamp Oh horror this game was first
shown off at e3 last year and is only in
its alpha stages but we have plenty to
talk about here are a few crucial tips
and things we think you should know
number one this isn't pub G and anyone
can survive the stated point of each
round is to find three clues using your
dark sight that lead you and every other
two-man team to a boss monster that
someone then has to kill vanish and
extract
however showdowns really more about PvP
because only one team can extract with
the boss tokens and if you die you lose
your hunters progress permanently as
well as half of your experience that
goes towards a persistent leveling
system if you survive by making it to
any labelled extraction point you can
level up your hunter with additional
health and perks so going for the boss
monster is actually a pretty big risk
that you don't necessarily need to take
instead of that you can just grab clues
and farm zombies before getting out on
your own
likewise if your partner gets killed
there's really no reason to risk it just
get out note that extractions go much
faster with both teammates alive if you
get to the point where you've lost all
of your hunters you can recruit new
level zero ones for free but they'll be
weaker than players who survive a few
rounds
number two zip it a lot of showdown is
about listening and staying quiet as
long as possible if you start shooting
infected and triggering crows and horses
and dogs other teams will come find you
and get the drop likewise you need to
pay attention to other teams making
those same mistakes melee weapons do
have a heavy attack that can drop most
infected with the least amount of noise
you do want to kill them for XP so don't
avoid fighting just keep it quiet
be aware that some throwables such as
fire lanterns cause Ami's to scream a
lot
[Applause]
number three ambushes are key teams that
kill level bosses still have to extract
with their banishment booty and as soon
as they head for the exit a large
lightning storm shows where they are on
the map at all times
letting other teams do the dirty work
greatly lower the risk of you getting
shot in the back while doing it yourself
a good strategy is to guess what
extraction point you think that team
might head for and then go straight
there during the lengthy banishment
process you can see banishment process
in the upper left corner of your screen
if everything works out most of the
remaining hunters will have killed each
other and you can mop up the survivors
also proximity voice chat is on so if
you're discussing that brilliant plan
you have to ambush another team know
that they can hear you his buddies up
here number four have a shotgun if
you're gonna ignore all of the last
thing I said and you want to go fight
other players at banished points which
are usually inside go by or bring a
shotgun in the alpha build shotguns are
the only viable PvP weapon at close
range with the shortest time to kill so
if you don't have one equipped keep your
fights outdoors and at range where you
can actually win number five headshot if
you can find it there are a number of
infected enemies with heads in various
GUI places and some are far more
dangerous than others 1 ranged attacker
can send swarms your way and her head is
hanging off by her side other infected
can charge at you or do you burning
damage which leaves you unable to
bandage yourself for periods of time the
most dangerous unit we encountered was
actually a pack of dogs that can Maul
you to death while also giving away your
position to other players so it's
important to learn your undead and how
to take them down oh and don't forget
that Friendly Fires on as you wildly
swing that hatchet next to your
partner's head so far we've had a pretty
good time with hunt showdowns alpha
we're not entirely sold on losing your
hunter permanently when you die because
in a PvP focused game you're bound to
die a lot by design we'll have to see if
the continuous progress system called
bloodline makes up for that what do you
guys think about this style of PvP do
you enjoy the added tension or does it
seem a bit unfair let's talk about it in
the comments below and we'll bring you
more on hunt showdown as we continue to
see the game thanks for watching
you